hello i'm jd mccrary and i play young
simba and disney's the lion king
i'm john favreau i directed the the new
version of disney's the lion king
hey guys i'm shahady wright joseph and i
play young nala in disney the lion king
hi i'm seth rogan i play pumbaa and i'm
billy eichner and i play timon
hi i'm alfred woodard and i play saravi
hi i'm georgetolegio4 i'm playing scar
in the new lion king
i'm florence kasoma and i play shenzi
shenzi is one of the hyenas
i am eric andre and i'm playing azizi uh
i'm a
indian stand-up comic from new york city
and i was on uh parks and rec
it's an aziz ansari joke i'm a hyena
it wasn't a very good joke and i'm
already being sued by aziz
and by walt disney and action
[Music]
which of these iconic disney villain
tunes would you want to belt out at your
next karaoke night
be prepared gaston poor unfortunate
souls
hell fire mother knows best or friends
on the other side
some of these are obscure very i don't
know half of them i would know his best
i'd go poor unfortunate souls i'm gonna
go for unfortunate souls too
i like poor unfortunate souls uh i don't
know any of these
is gaston be our guest be our guest to
be our guest
now gaston do you know the song beauty
and the beast
yeah but is that the one that's like uh
no
yeah yeah great for unfortunate souls i
was gonna pray that's my favorite
you can still think no it's all right i
think i think gaston would be fun to do
it
unfortunately oh friends on the other
side i love it so much you do
yes that's my favorite song be prepared
what is hellfire
you're watching hellfire on the disney
channel
question two pick the grub you would
most like to munch on
okay i don't want to munch on any grubs
we have the shield bug
the ant dragonfly worms
grasshopper and ladybug lunch on
grasshopper
i guess i'm gonna go grasshopper too
because they seem the most like
food yeah did anyone pick ladybug that
seems you're a straight
[ __ ] if you choose you know i kinda
wanna munch on a ladybug
i ought to go for the ladybug i've
already tried an ant so i'll eat that
one
i'll go with worms okay because i have
eaten
grasshopper before so i would munch on
the grass well it's between the ant and
the dragonfly
ants are good i've had chocolate covered
ants before all right let's do that then
i'm going to say shield bug because it
has greens and i feel like you are what
you eat and you gotta like get your
greens
which adjective would your closest
friends use to describe you adventurous
creative
funny determined loyal or intelligent
i would say creative because we're like
i gotta go before i gotta go be right
now
we're gonna say we're the same i mean of
course you're creative because you like
make movies
but i think that i would be creative and
definitely creative because i
make jingles off the top of my head so
really so yeah also creative too because
she's
yeah you have to choose creative uh i
guess determined
i'd like to think funny but i know it's
not the answer about all my friendship
i'm gonna say determined
i'm gonna say creative i'm not
adventurous i'm not creative i'm funny
you're so funny i'm gonna funny yeah go
with funny
probably none of these words
unfortunately
definitely not loyal yeah did you do
yeah do you have more of a bummer than
you would think
yeah um strangely okay without other
human interactions yeah exactly
uh i'll go with funny oh you're gonna
choose funny uh
well you are similar billy i know all
right i'm gonna choose funny
which character from the original film
would you most like to have as your
partner in crime
shenzhen timon nala pumbaa
zazu rafiki well chanting stick is
sitting right next to me so i guess i'm
gonna choose
wisely or i'm gonna get slapped um
well i go for rafiki because i always
like good advice uh
i don't thought you didn't pick me i'm
gonna pick boom before anything like
that
hurts doesn't it echo with nala
ah yeah nice you know i just love zazu
so i'm just i'm just gonna i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go
there timon oh that's nice of you yeah
whereas i'm going with
shenzhen good
maybe timon i feel like he gives really
good advice but in
a bad way but like i feel like if he
used
his advice for good he would be like a
therapist or something
i'll go person with nala nala is pretty
tough
and brave and smart i'm going i mean who
wouldn't want to hang out with beyonce
when someone you love is in trouble oh
wow happens a long segment
but weirdly i live a life where that
happens on a weekly basis
constantly just being like seth it's me
someone i love is in trouble it's really
i'm having a problem yeah
when someone you love is in trouble you
hurry and to help them
assess the situation first call someone
else for help
run away wait for them to ask you for
help
love who what bye-bye
love who went by right up top
and i assess the situation first yeah
you're smart
it definitely depends on the nature of
the trouble are the cops after them
i think there are some situations when
waiting for them to ask you for help is
probably a good idea
well there are other situations where
hurrying into help is probably the
better idea
let's say their butt's on fire i'm going
to hurry in and help him
i'm going to assess the situation first
assess the situation
figure out what's going on because if
you don't know what's going on if you
call someone to help
you can't tell them anything we're going
to assess the situation we don't have
the luxury
right dad what i gotta run over even if
i fall off the cliff i gotta run after
that
assess the situation for seems like it
is the most brutal
i think that's the most pragmatic yeah
i'm gonna go with that or or run away or
just run away
which of the following locations would
you most like to go on on vacation a
beautiful lake
an open range a buzzing city an african
safari
mountain view babbling brook i'm gonna
say a beautiful lake because i'm a water
person
i'm gonna say an african safari actually
i'll say a buzzing city because i'm
about to go to
london and tokyo as part of the
promotional field
and i'm looking forward to it i prefer
the city
i'm gonna say africa just because it's
the one continent i haven't been to yet
people but really i'm gonna get there
and i'm gonna be stressed out and i'm
gonna have like allergies and stuff i
probably wanna babbling brook
all right we'll do africa i've never
been to africa before my mom has been
wow
but i feel like i would want to go i
think you like it i'm gonna maybe we
should say safari because of lion king
maybe but i actually am terrified to go
in a safari and would never want to oh
wow all right
i actually would it's it's the one thing
of all these things i haven't done
all right i'm gonna do safari i've been
a brooks you've been a brooks
i've been on a brook i've been on i've
been in a buzzing city
i am too hard
beautiful i'm gonna say just to be
different i'm gonna say a beautiful lake
do it which quote from the original film
speaks to you
the most hakuna matata remember who you
are i laugh in the face of danger
who said that oh yes the past can hurt
i'm surrounded by
idiots we are all
connected i'm surrounded by idiots i'm
surrounded
i'm surrounded by idiots is a good one
and i'll do we are all connected
comes around
i really liked the movie when beyonce
said i laugh in the face of danger yeah
that was a great moment i'm gonna choose
that one i'm gonna go with i'm
surrounded by idiots
okay greg i'm surrounded by idiots
[Music]
i'm gonna go with um hakuna matata
it's such a stoner answer and finally
for no particular reason
i'll pick a beyonce music video crazy in
love
partition single ladies put a ring on it
formation drunk in love and run the
world girls
run the world i just listen to formation
and watch the video so
don't that run the world oh really i
like formation i really enjoy formation
formation that's easy so i'm gonna go
with um
um crazy in love i gotta go away i gotta
go crazy in love
who'd you get i got mufasa i got scar oh
no how is that possible
why because i want to go to a beautiful
lake
you're like scar's gay who wants to go
no because you're you chose to hang out
with shenzi
also that was it that was your one i got
mufasa i'm a poised king through and
through i'm humble all
hard-working unafraid to stick up for
your loved ones
you're the absolute coolest
congratulations
mine says you got scar you're determined
to succeed and will let absolutely
nothing and no one get in your way you
please
also pretty accurate you're like really
badass
yeah that's we i would say this is
accurate for me
totally yeah i can barely see
i can barely look at it apparently i'm
most like scar i got mufasa and i'm
simba i got mufasa
yes it's true i got scar oh come on
i got nala what that was the smartest
character
people listen when you speak or raw and
care about what you have to say
also you are
that's beyonce fair mine says you have
cholera
[Music]
scar i don't know he looks diseased
what is it true do i have cholera yes
okay that was great i
agree she's the smartest character in
the movie that's the only reason simba
returns but i do have to say i'm just
not very patient
oh you're impatient you should patient
you seem so grounded you're
dropping off because they're the camera
really yeah yeah but you filled the room
you exude confidence
i feel like you could like break a wine
glass with your mind
[Music]
you